um okay
so uh decoherence is a
like very on the surface mundane
thing about quantum uh mechanics and
it's just
uh the fact that um as
you uh like as you have okay so you have
some particle in a superposition let's
say a superposition of spin up and spin
down
and then something interacts with it
let's say a photon of light
and the photon of light will act
differently if the particle is spin up
or if it's spinned down so that light
particle will go into a different state
depending on which of those two
properties it's in um so now in quantum
mechanics we would say that it's
entangled with uh with the original
particle
because um its state depends on the
state of the original particle so that's
like what entanglement is
um and so then uh okay like that's
that's all good
but now imagine that that photon just
like leaves
and you never see it again and you will
never be able to measure it
but you try and measure your original
particle now even
if your original particle is in a
superposition normally you'd be able to
tell that it's in a superposition you
can do like a double slit experiment on
it something similar
um just to tell that it is in that super
position
but even though it's still in a super
position um and like
nothing has changed from the quantum
mechanics point of view because you have
no you haven't got
access to that photon if you do the math
you can
like show that this particle now acts as
if
it's collapsed to one of those two
states like you will not be able to tell
the difference between a collapsed
particle
and what's really happening which is
it's still in a superposition but
a superposition that involves this
photon that is now inaccessible
um and so that's like yeah on the
surface a bit mundane
but um the implications are really
profound because
here is a mechanism by which you can get
measurement collapse without measurement
collapse like so something that
looks and feels to us exactly like
measurement collapse like mathematically
entirely equivalent and yet all that's
happening is normal quantum mechanics
and so you can just get rid of that last
postulate of quantum mechanics entirely
um and just replace it with like
just just just delete it and you still
get the same results
sorry when you say you can get rid of
the last postulate of quantum mechanics
you're referring to
oh yes the the measurement postulate so
the collapse postulate um
that so like yeah there's the the thing
that's really
nasty about quantum mechanics and like
the the i think real
problem with quantum mechanics is that
there's two systems
there's like what how quantum quantum
objects
like act when there is no
measures around and no devices around to
measure them
they just like evolve unitarily it's
very nice
but then suddenly as soon as you add
something that you call a measurement
device
and like who knows what that is um you
have to have like
different rules of physics that are like
incompatible like they just don't work
together
and like this is just untenable
mathematically and philosophically like
it's just
ugly um whereas the the
the whole d coherence thing gives us a
way out what it says is
forget about that second regime
measurements are not real
measurements are a um a phenomenological
thing that comes from just the regular
um quad mechanics uh like there is never
measurement collapse
instead um there's only superpositions
but
because some parts of those
superpositions become inaccessible to
you as like you add more particles and
they all become entangled and then those
particles fly off or whatever
you can't measure them your your object
that is still in a superposition now
looks as if it's been measured
and therefore like that is like
measurement but it's not a real thing
it's just a
an emergent property